et député européen du rassemblement
national tu libères collard merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur l'hers et france
une règle fait après cet attentat
on a une claque qui sonne dans le coeur
voilà il ya il ya un sentiment de 2,2 de
lassitude devant la la répétition de ces
actions criminelles mais en même temps
un sentiment de colère
bon on peut pas employer certains mots
parce que ils sont interdits dans le
catéchisme magnétique médiatique mais
moi je suis vraiment très en colère
alors c'est une colère bien sûr
républicaine c'est une colère légal mais
c'est une vraie colère c'est une vraie
colère gilbert collard actuellement vous
êtes en colère contre qui je suis en
colère à la fois contre les hommes les
femmes les journalistes les politiciens
qui collectivement depuis des années des
années ont vu venir le mal et l'ont
laissé s'installer par une espèce de
complicité qui dénoncé aujourd'hui dans
plein de livres
c'est un ancien inspecteur d'éducation
générale qui se demandent comment
comment l'intégrisme islamique à puis
s'installe dans l'école
c'est un journaliste qui fait une
enquête sur la complicité des élus avec
les extrémistes islamiques radicaux et
c'est bon donc il y a un lien de
complicité de tolérance depuis des
années qui a permis à ce terreau de
l'islamisme radical que je me garde bien
de confondre les islamistes radicaux
extrémistes avec celles et ceux qui
pratiquent leur religion d'une manière
classique et normale mais on a favorisé
le terrain tout ce qui arrive
aujourd'hui et puis on sait également
désarmer les points de vue du point de
vue du droit quand on emploie le mot
guerre on va voir on va toutes les
vierges effarouchées s'indigner mais si
c'est pas une guerre s'il ressemble
quand même très très très fortement 1
on est en est alors on reproche à
estrosi
la formule qui l'employait tout à
l'heure à propos des temps de paix
d'anti faut sortir
moi je suis pour l'état de droit mais je
suis pour un état de droit
antiterroriste vous comprenez un anti un
état de droit fortement anti terroriste
d'islamisme radical et de toute forme
d'extrémisme du reste d'eau qui viennent
il faut que notre état de droit s'adapte
à la situation c'est pas sortir de
l'état de droit que de l'adapter à la
situation et je pense qu'on ferait bien
de s'intéresser aux méthodes quotidienne
qu'utilise l'état israélien
sylvie suis quand même protéger ses
citoyens et ses citoyens et on aurait
beaucoup à apprendre de la manière dont
ils procèdent pour assurer la protection
des uns et des autres mais on ne le fait
pas et on voit que de jour en jour bah
le terrorisme frappe tulle décapite et
gorges et c'est absolument intolérable
on ne peut plus continuer de cette
manière là il faut tant que petit billet
une adaptation de l'état de droit
quand vous pensez que on avait une
mesure qui nous permettait de surveiller
les terroristes une fois qu'ils étaient
libérés de les maintenir dans une espèce
de surveillance et bien le conseil
constitutionnel a supprimé cette mesure
donc il ya vraiment une adaptation à
faire à la réalité de l'état actuel tout
en restant dans un état bien évidemment
de droit monsieur colère vous parlais à
l'instant de l'adaptation de l'état de
droit
comment on
bon l'adapt tout simplement en en
s'émancipant principalement des
contraintes de européenne on a alors
qu'elle il ya 5 vers où on peut les
énumérer mais il y a il y à la cndh
il y a le conseil constitutionnel il y à
la cour européenne et caetera et caetera
et la contestation
et puis au dessus de la cour de
cassation vous avez la la la la la
commission européenne des droits de
l'homme blanc qui décide quasiment par
supériorité aux décisions du 6 novembre
on est donc on est donc complètement
paralysé et et et le conseil
constitutionnel retoque des mesures qui
seraient d'une utilité évidente pour lui
pour terrorisme je voudrais donner un
exemple tout à l'heure un bon donc il
faut un état de droit bien sûr mais à
l'état de droit antiterroriste par
exemple en israël quand un individu est
sérieusement soupçonné d'un possible
passage à l'acte terroriste ont
l'appréhendent et on le présente à une
juridiction
donc l'état de droit l'état du juge
intervient et là on apprécie si les
risques sont réels ou pas mais il y a
quand même à ce moment là une alerte qui
est donné
nous on ne fait pas on peut pas le faire
même si l'individu est très dangereux
d'abord on n'arrivera pas à l'expulser
parce que c'est très compliqué parce
qu'elle a des recours
alors monsieur collard par exemple au
niveau des fiches et s on le rappelle
qu'ils n'ont pas commis de délit mais
qui souligne lentement km de tuyaux de
lagon oui je sais mais qu'est ce qu'on
devrait en faire justement de ces fiches
est un parfait respect de l'état de
droit
alors d'abord fichiers savons rien dire
vous savez pas ce qu'on peut te fiche
est pour des faits qui n'ont rien à voir
avec le terrorisme
il faudrait donc qu'il y ait une
spécification très travaillé très
étudiée et qu' on puisse déféré
juge à l'individu sont sur le pont
duquel il existe des indices graves
précis au concordants qui pourrait
passer à l'acte terroriste et à partir
de ce moment-là il y à un débat et c'est
le juge qui décide s'il ya lieu ou non
de prendre des mesures que la loi peut
énumérer une surveillance un contrôle
avant qu'il y ait passage à l'acte
criminel mais parce qu'on aura des
indices précis concordant grave qu'il ya
une possibilité de passage à l'acte
entre nous ça aurait au moins le mérite
de foudre un coup de pied dans la
fourmilière et en dernier recours c'est
le juge qui se prononce bien évidemment
il ne s'agit pas de donner à la police
le moindre pouvoir juridictionnel le
moindre pouvoir d'interpeller interpellé
d'incarcérer le ca serait une folie
ce serait la mort de l'état de droit
mais l'intervention du jus dans un cas
pareil sort et les choses avant la vie
très utile parce qu'on ne va pas quand
même continuer à compter les morts
c'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui on
compte les morts on allume des bougies
ont déposé des fleurs
le président de la république se déplace
fait un discours
on enterre les morts on les oublie et
d'autres mots reviennent qui font qu'on
oublie les morts précédent et ainsi de
suite mon objectivement plus tolérable
plus tolérable et il faut frapper encore
une fois contre tous les extrémismes
tous sans aucune distinction selon vous
est-ce que les actes terroristes sont
intensifiées actuellement en france a
maintenant des faut il faut il faut être
aveugle pour ne pas le voir ne serait-ce
que depuis depuis une semaine
y est je pense que c'est en lien
contrairement à ce que disait tout à
l'heure
vos intervenants je pense que c'est en
bien directement avec
les déclarations du président r daugan
lucky man en donne l'impression de ne
pas se sentir concerné en présentant des
pans doléances par l'intermédiaire de
son ministre mais il a il a chauffé à
blanc toute une communauté musulmane
extrémiste
il suffit du reste de regarder elle
saisira de regarder la télévision
algérienne de regarder les télévisions
des pays
mon des pays musulmans pour s'en rendre
compte que il y a eu vraiment une
excitation réel par le président
arrogant contre la france et contre
contre la france chrétienne ne
l'oublions pas se fit un prêtre que que
que l'on égorge art aujourd'hui c'est
des chrétiens en train de prier dans une
église
il ya donc quelque chose qui touche
objectivement aux fondements religieux
de notre identité il faut pas il faut
pas feindre de l'ignorer faut avoir le
courage de dire pourquoi la france est
elle prise pour cible selon vous mais la
france est prise pour cible d'abord
parce que ella ella elle a une tradition
de 2,2 de présence en orient et au moyen
orient de culture chrétienne catholique
connu ensuite parce que on a eu nos
caricatures et on a quand même le droit
au pays de voltaire de faire des
caricatures on peut quand même se se
moquer des redoublants aussi bon et ses
caricatures ont provoqué dans des dans
des états où le blasphème existe des
réactions qui ont été exacerbées et puis
la france c'est aussi le pays d'une
liberté de ton de vire au civc des
salles est de moins en moins qui dérange
tous et tous et tous et tous ces culs
bénis de l'extrémisme
gilbert collard merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions on vous garde certainement
sur notre table mais a tout de suite on
va retrouver notre reporter katia et
cancale en direct de
katia bonjour alors on observe un retour
au calme dans le centre ville
oui et retour au calme ça c'est sûr il
ya une grande solennité ici à nice de
nombreux badauds se sont regroupés sur
l'avenue jean médecin
nous sommes à peu près à 200 mètres de
la basilique je pense que le quartier
qui est pour le moment bouclé ce
bouclage justement va s'alléger au fil
des heures mais comme le président
manuel macron vient de rendre visite aux
abords de la basilique il a rendu visite
aux forces de l'ordre bien donc pour le
moment la présence policière est intense
ici police nationale police municipale
camions de crs et des pompiers
donc de nombreuses forces de l'ordre
sont déployés aux abords de cette
basilique pour vous parler de l'émotion
ici déjà il ya un véritable silence et
puis des vies d'amendé réaction de
sidération de peur je propose d'écouter
une habitante premiers sentiments maurer
deuxième sentiment c est l état de
sidération tout simplement de savoir que
à nouveau des personnes perdent la vie
de manière tout à fait innocente c'est
quand même mentalement et moralement
quelque chose de très très difficile à
gérer donc dès maintenant il faut
essayer de penser à leurs familles tout
simplement
et puis faire appel à la solidarité ne
pas lâcher l'excusé ya beaucoup
d'émotions malheureusement c'est très
difficile
donc vous voyez l'émotion est vive ici à
nice les personnes sont incrédules parce
que désormais évidemment elles ont peur
tout cela fait écho à cette terrible
tragédie en 2005 et 2006 avec ce camion
qui avait foncé sur la foule
occasionnant 86 morts donc c'est on peut
pas parler de redites parce que les
habitants ici font bien la distinction
mais ils sont accablés aussi bien les
riverains d'ailleurs que les forces de
l'ordre que nous avons croisés tout à
l'heure katia technique merci beaucoup
d'avoir été en direct avec nous je
rappelle peut être en direct de nice on
vous reprend 1
pendant cette édition spéciale consacrée
à l'attentât de nice ce matin gilbert
collard député européen du rassemblement
national est toujours en direct avec
nous sur rt france monsieur kohler
beaucoup part du renforcement de la
sécurité après cet attentat
est ce une urgence l'on voit en france
mais c'est tellement une urgence qu'on
est en retard quand on pense qu'on vient
maintenant des levées d'un niveau le
plan vigipirate et ça n'était pas encore
malgré la décapitation de ce malheureux
professeur la nuit on a du mal à
comprendre le temps qu'il faut pour que
les événements arrivent au cerveau
gouvernementale on a en a on a
l'impression que les informations
chemine très très lentement
alors quand on dit qu'en l'état des
camps étaient en état de guerre
cela provoque des indignations
sémantique mais quand on voit les les
violences commises les les assassinats
commis les égorgements la décapitation
en on est bien obligé de dire qu'il
s'agit là d'une forme de guerre et qu'on
doit avoir une adaptation immédiate en
forme de riposte au quotidien je dis
bien au quotidien à ces attaques
j'avais du temps j'étais député national
fait une proposition de loi qui aurait
permis aux anciens gendarmes aux anciens
policiers aux anciens militaires
après un examen psychiatrique après des
tests de compétence de pouvoir
éventuellement porter une arme
avec le renouvellement tous les six mois
du port d'armes pour tourner dans la
foule anonyme des anciens représentants
de l'ordre toujours habité par l'idée de
représenter l'ordre qui pourrait en cas
d'urgence devant le surgissement
inattendue du terrorisme parce que c'est
toujours dans l'inattendu ça se produit
réagir
on n'a pas voulu on n'a pas voulu
et pourtant et pourtant que d'hommes à
la retraite aujourd'hui qui pourrait
constituer une espèce de réserve
anonyme voilà il faut s'adapter à cette
guerre des meurtriers anonyme des
meurtriers surgissant des des meurtriers
prêt à tout il faut qu'on s'adapte mais
on on a une heure une lenteur à
s'adapter qui comptait par les maures
qui tu en voilà c'est complètement
dramatique
monsieur en colère donc une riposte
selon vous des recettes unanimes il faut
au risque riposter à tous ces actes
terroristes justement comment on l'a
priorise 7h y passe et comment
l'organisme organise comme jeu comme je
vous le dis en s'inspirant en cessant de
de considérer que l'on alors bien sûr
nos services font un travail qui
remarquable
ils ont réussi à déjouer de nombreux
attentats et on ne dira jamais assez à
quel point
ces hommes de l'ombre sont efficaces
mais ce qui caractérise l'attentât
terroriste aujourd'hui c'est sa
survenance inattendue dans dans des
lieux où on ne les attendait pas donc il
faut pouvoir riposter dans ces moments
là il ya eu une réaction rapide de la
police municipale ce qui est déjà un
progrès parce qu'il ya quelques années
la police municipale n'avait pas cette
efficacité et quand vous pensez qu'il
existe des mères en france qui
voudraient désarmer leurs polices
municipales il faut qu'on comprenne que
la réponse elle doit ce lot fait dans le
quotidien
tant qu'on n'aura pas ça c'est ce que
les israéliens ont su faire à merveille
tant qu'on n'aura pas d'aidé des soldats
anonymes du quotidien prêt à riposter
on arrivera en même temps que le
corbillard chaque fois chaque fois donc
ce que je ce que je préconise c'est
vraiment quand sadate à l' attaque
inattendue dans le quotidien en
mobilisant des forces que nous avons qui
sont des forces aux petits peuvent être
tout à fait républicaine complètement
inclus dans l'état de droit
antiterroriste et qu'on se doit
d'utiliser emmanuel macron l'annoncé
tout à l'heure la mobilisation de 3000 à
7000 militaires pour protéger notamment
les lieux de culte en cette période
oui oui oui mais là encore pourquoi
maintenant pour peu pourquoi attendre
que tombent les morts pour prendre les
décisions
pourquoi attendre enfin quand même on
sait qu'ils veulent notre peau il rompt
pas du reste on en a vu d'autres entre
nous un et là ils sont des illusions
ces extrémistes s'il s'imagine que
on va reculer là il se trompe vraiment
vraiment d'abord on est capable de ne
pas faire de confusion entre les bons et
les et les mauvais les détestables 1 et
ensuite on a toujours su dans notre
histoire réagir mais faut-il encore
qu'on comprenne bien que c'est dans le
quotidien que le terrorisme se love se
cache et et qu'il faut arriver dans
l'inattendu à le débusquer et ça ça
passe par par le recours à des mesures
dans dans celle dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure qui auraient pu être
adoptées il ya maintenant cinq ans ou 6
ans 1
gilbert collard merci d'avoir été on
dirait